en el centro de sfax cientos de
migrantes duermen en la calle desde hace
dos días turbas locales les echaron de
sus viviendas muchos tuvieron que
dejarlo todo atrás como Mary de sierra
nuestras condiciones de vida son muy
difíciles porque no hay comida
suficiente para todos y ahora Estamos en
vivienda definitivamente tienen que
ponernos en un lugar seguro
los migrantes se mantienen Unidos por
seguridad Mary no puede contactar a su
embajada porque Sierra Leona no tiene
representación diplomática en túnez
otros como Mohamed de burkina faso no
quieren quedarse en el país ni un día
más si los tunecinos ya no nos quieren
que se pongan en contacto con nuestra
embajada para encontrarnos una solución
Y en lugar de recogernos para llevarnos
al Desierto más de 500 migrantes fueron
transportados a la fuerza a las
desérticas fronteras con Libia y Argelia
pero las autoridades tunecinas lo niegan
en sfax muchos lugareños se oponen a
este trato de los migrantes negros
algunos les llevan comida y agua
rechazar a nuestros vecinos por favor
tenemos que hacer un llamamiento todos
tenemos que unirnos para encontrar
soluciones
para mí la única pregunta urgente es qué
debemos hacer ante esta catastrófica
situación humanitaria
la ciudad carece de las políticas o
estructuras para ocuparse de los
migrantes que quieren llegar a Europa
las autoridades tunecinas liberan a los
migrantes que detienen en el mar que
luego vuelven a intentar el viaje Ese
fue el caso de estos daneses que llevan
tres meses viviendo en un parque Aquí es
muy difícil sobre todo para las mujeres
no tenemos condiciones de higiene tú
nacido negociando con la Unión Europea
para reprimir la migración irregular
presidente kaiza con frecuencia que no
desempeñará el papel de guardia de
fronteras de Europa y el país no tiene
ley de